what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so we're going to do another r tutorial
today and it's going to be on
base r so functions
and characteristics of r that don't
require you to dabble into packages at
all
so once you got r installed and
hopefully you're using rstudio as your
uh
as your gui for r uh all these
functionalities are right there and a
lot of these are things that you
probably should get acquainted with
sooner rather than later because
a lot of the things we're going to walk
through here they're either essential
or really really helpful things that if
you don't know that they exist
you could be just taking a lot longer to
do things than you should be
uh now in this tutorial i'm gonna be
going back and forth a little bit
between this cheat sheet
and our markdown document that i've
drawn up for this tutorial
and that's just because there's a few
functions here that i think it's really
helpful for you to see exactly what's
going on there
but for the most part i'm going to be
walking through this cheat sheet
now this cheat sheet i'm going to have a
link in the description of this video
similarly this our markdown document is
going to be available on my github
also in the description so uh before
as usual before we get into this uh
number one please take
one second of time to smash the like
button to this video because that really
does help my content reach a larger
audience
also in the description i will have a
link to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me that way it would be
massively appreciated
all right so there are two pages to this
cheat sheet and for the most part
i'm going to go from one page to the
next and i'm gonna go down each of these
columns there's a couple points in which
i'm going to have to jump around because
i think a couple of the
functions are somewhat related to each
other but for the most part that's what
we're going to do here
so the very first function on this whole
cheat sheet is arguably the most
important function in the entire r
ecosystem and that's the question mark
function
uh also known as the help function so
when you run this
for a particular function it's going to
pull up the help documentation for
it so let's see an example of that if we
go into r here
and just i'm gonna run a couple chunks
of code here but
uh if i go ahead and do question mark
for the mutate function which i'm
which i've been using here i just run
the question mark function like that
bam it's going to pull up that help
documentation on the uh
on the right side here so i do this all
the time it's uh it's very
it's going to take a long time before
you memorize all the syntax for every
function that you could possibly use
most people are never going to get there
at all so get very comfy with doing that
similarly if you want to pull up the
help documentation let's say for an
entire package
you could do that by calling this help
function directly so say help
package equals deployer in parentheses
that will pull up
all the functionality on cran uh for the
deployer
package so that's awesome so this str
function is another one of the absolute
most important functions in all of r
so let's see an example of that now i'm
using the
iris data set just because that's an
absolute classic
comes built into r you can pull it into
your environment by using
the data function and then iris inside
of it but if we just look at the
str function let's take a look at it
let's use str of iris
and then bam look at that we see the
structure of this
data set or this object iris we see that
it's a data frame with 150 observations
of five variables
and it lists all these variables with
their names
as well as what types of variables these
things are and some examples of them so
5.1 4.9 4.7 all
uh realizations of the variable
sepal.length
as well as the species variable that's a
factor with three levels
super helpful stuff now very closely
related to the str function is the
summary function
this is going to give you a little bit
more information
specifically it's going to give you
things like the five number summary in
the case of these continuous variables
now species is a factor variable so it's
going to break down for each of the
different levels of that factor
what are the counts for each of them so
very very helpful
and if you want to do only one variable
at a time you can do that
but iris has only five variables to it
so
running the summary for the entire uh
data frame i think makes a lot of sense
here
now one other function which you should
be aware of is the names
of function now this is really nice if
you just want a quick and dirty overview
of what the names of the data frame are
like here we go we've got a character
vector
uh of the names of uh of iris and if we
want to do something like we want to
modify the names or we want to
you know pass it inside of another
function using the names function makes
that super
uh super easy to do
so we go back over here uh by now
if you've seen my previous tutorials
which i recommend doing so before
this video uh obviously you'd be
familiar then with install.packages and
library
uh your first go around with things you
have to run install.packages
so that you have an installation of the
package available for r
to find then once that's done you use
the
library function you'll load all the
functions in that package into your
into your session and then you're good
to go uh
data you've already that function you've
already seen i did that to bring the
iris data set into my environment
now if you've seen my first r tutorial
you saw where i did this deep plier
colon colon select thing and the reason
you may need to do that is because
taking this function select for instance
the select function
exists inside the deployer package but
it's also inside a package called
mass so when that happens and you have
multiple of these packages
and there are conflicts like that r can
get confused like
okay which package do you want to use
the select function from
so if you put this deployer colon colon
prefix in front
that removes that confusion for r so
sometimes you'll need to do that
particularly with
the deployer package uh working
directory stuff
so the get wd function that will tell
you what your working directory is
uh as far as set wd you can specify
a file path inside of that function and
it will change your working directory
now you can specify that a big long file
path
let's say you're doing something like
reading a data set in or you're
you want to write a data set and have it
show up in
uh in your machine somewhere that you
can access
you could write that entire long file
path but
if you're just working inside of one
folder just
write that file path to that folder
inside of set wd
and then it's going to make your life a
lot easier because you could just write
jumping ahead a little bit here file.txt
let's say you're doing a write.table
file.text
that would output right to that folder
that you've specified inside of your
working directory
so just a couple more things which
highly recommend getting acquainted with
here
now the second column is all about
things pertaining to vectors
and most of this is very straightforward
so you've seen this c function if you
saw our tutorial
4 that i did but let's say you have
these elements 2
4 and 6 put them in this c function
uh c stands for concatenate that
basically bundles these things into one
vector then you can work with the vector
in and of itself
uh this two colon six thing is an
integer sequence so that'll return
two three four five and six this scq
function is a nice one
uh the seq stands for sequence so it go
so the arguments to it are the minimum
the maximum
and by so you could do two
min minimum equals two maximum equals
three and
the increments are 0.5 so you would
return
2 2.5 and 3. similarly you've got the
rep function
now it's got these arguments times and
each and the difference is
let's say you've got rep 1 colon 2 times
equal 3 would return
1 2 1 2 1 2. then rep
one colon two each equals three will
return one one one
two two two so very helpful function for
uh you know spinning some data together
that's uh
i use these quite frequently now for
some of your core vector functions
you can do sort that will just sort your
uh your vector the default is
alphabetically but you can
uh you can do things like reverse
alphabetically for instance the
rev function will help you do that uh
table
will turn your count and then unique
that's a super helpful one because that
will uh
show you just your uh just your unique
values analogous to something like a
distinct in
sql if you're familiar with that now
when you start
subsetting and selecting elements of
your vector as a general rule whenever
you see these brackets
that's going to involve some form of
subsetting so
x bracket 4 that's going to return the
fourth element
you can do this in a uh inverse fashion
so x
negative four will return all but the
fourth element
we can do um a sequence here so x
brackets two to four is going to return
the second through fourth elements
similarly we can make that negative uh
or we can just do
the first and the fifth element by just
putting those inside of a vector
this concatenate one and five will
return the first
and fifth element of vector x
uh then just one thing to keep in mind
here we've got the equals equals
now equals in r just the single equals
is typically an assign
operator but equals equals is a logical
check
so when we put x and then in brackets
x equals equals 10 that's going to
subsets to the cases where
x equals 10 is a true statement so
subset to elements that are equal to 10.
similarly we could do that with elements
that are less than zero
and you've got your operators for uh
equal to
not equal to greater than less than you
know and so on and so forth
uh this in operator is a super helpful
thing which i use all the time
you can subset to x being in the set one
two and five
again i use that all the time and then
if you have names to your vector
for instance here you could subset to
the element in x that has the name
apple moving on to the last section of
this cheat sheet we have our for loop
and our while loop
those are the key loops inside of our as
well as the the if statement is super
important as well
uh now this the key syntax piece here is
that you do need these curly braces
so uh just keep that in mind uh
for some other things like the spacing
here uh
and the indentation r is typically
pretty forgiving with that kind of thing
so just set this up generally with
making sure you have the curly braces
and that it's generally readable for an
audience that's not you
now a couple things that i want to show
here because there's also a key
function called the if else function
which is not on this cheat sheet
so i'm going to use the if else function
to create a new variable
uh inside a new data frame that i'm
going to call iris 2.
now i want to create a variable called
large sepal and i'm going to use the if
else function to do that
now how the if else function works is
there's going to be
some statements to evaluate is that true
or false
then if it's true it's going to return a
particular value
if it's false it's going to return
another value now i want to check for is
simple length greater than sixth and uh
simple with
also greater than three now if that's
true
my my variable large set ball is going
to be equal
true if this is not true it's going to
be equal
false so let's just do that
and bam i've created a new uh
variable called large simple which is
false 127 times and true 23 times
this is typically the kind of context in
which i'll use the if else
function but i find this super super
helpful and it can be a
lot uh just syntactically cleaner than
writing a whole bunch of if else
statements
uh the other thing i'm going to show you
is creating a function
so the the what i've created here is
this custom function called fair to cell
and what i'm doing here is i created a
um a vector called
fair these are just temperatures here
and here in the detroit area where i
live that are in fahrenheit
and i created a function which is going
to convert
um a vector of values into celsius
so it's just going to perform the
conversion
formula that you use to go from
fahrenheit to celsius
so just create that function x
and it's going to return i'm going to
round uh
this new variable y that's created in
the middle of this
and i'm going to store that inside a new
variable
cell and then i return cell here and bam
it worked to convert my fahrenheit uh
vector into celsius so it's generally a
really good practice to get into
to write functions for things that
you're going to repeat more than once
and it's also good practice because over
time you're gonna end up doing a lot of
the same kind of functionality over and
over again
so if you've written functions for
things that you do a lot
you can end up saving yourself a ton of
time
so that just about covers uh this
section of the cheat sheet
again if statements and functions as we
go down things like reading tables and
reading csvs
writing tables and writing csvs or
things that you want to be familiar with
uh loading and saving uh our data files
and then the conditions moving on to the
second page of this cheat sheet we have
our variable types to start this off
now if you've seen my r tutorial for you
should be familiar with these already
but you've got
as dot logical as dot numeric etc etc
that will help you convert a variable
from one data type to another
so clean and easy to work with uh the
next thing are your math functions
and now it shouldn't surprise you that r
was built by statisticians for other
statisticians
so there's a lot of math options that
are available to you
so you've got a natural log function
exponential
max and min round to so and so decimal
places
round to so and so significant figures
there's a correlation function
you've got some mean median a quantile
function for
let's say you want the 25th quantile of
uh
of a vector you can return that there's
a rank function
there's variance and standard deviation
and then most of you should be familiar
with this one already but
obviously you've got variable assignment
and the assign
operator is this uh arrow thing
so let's say we want this scalar element
of a it's going to be one-dimensional
and we want it to be equal to apple
we can just assign apple to a then when
we call a
bam it's going to output apple so lastly
for this
section here then we've got the
environment and no i'm not talking about
the thing that's all around us that has
the air that we breathe and the water
that we drink and all that stuff
um this is easier to illustrate inside
of r because for newcomers to
programming a lot of you may be
unfamiliar with the concept of an
environment
but if you think through what i've done
so far in this script
i created this thing called dataset as
well as iris and iris2
now i can access those whenever i want
and do whatever i want with them i've
got these uh
vectors sal and fair as well as this
function that i've
created all of this is inside of my
environment
now if we want to return a list of the
objects that are
already loaded in the environment we've
got this ls function
and bam that's going to output for us
uh these objects that we can work with
as well as the fair to sell function
here
now if i wanted to and i just wanted to
remove everything inside of my
environment
you can do this rm list equals ls
functionality now watch what happens to
maya to everything that's listed in my
environment on the upper right side here
when i run this i'm gonna run it and bam
my environment is empty
so that's that's a clean thing that you
can do sometimes just to
free up some space for uh for yourself
and uh this is something that in if you
read a lot of people's code you're going
to see this right up front
second column of this page of the cheat
sheet is all about matrices
lists and data frames so if we step
through this
starting at the top we have matrices
again you've seen this if you've seen
our tutorial number four but just to go
over this again
uh if you have a matrix let's call it m
then you do
m two comma that's gonna access your uh
second row similarly if you do m comma
one
in brackets that's gonna return your
first column of m
and then let's say you do both of them
so you do m 2 comma 3
that's going to access that's going to
go to the second row
and then the third column and access the
element in that location
so rows followed by by columns is how
that works
then you've got some other uh matrix
operators like your transpose and your
matrix multiplication and your solve
function
uh now i'm actually going to move on to
data frames next
because i think for most people these
are a little simpler to understand
and you can put a data frame together in
this fashion right here
using the data.frame function so in this
example here
i would be i would create a data frame
with two variables
one of them would be x it would be just
one two three here
and then my second variable would be y
and it would have variable or values
uh a b and c now as far as how you
subset this r is amazingly flexible with
this
now i went back through this script and
i brought everything back into my
environment so don't freak out too much
here
but i have got my iris uh data frame
back in my environment here
now if i want to do iris dollar sign
sepal dot length
that's going to access the variable
simple.length from iris
and this is by far the most common way
that you're going to see people
accessing
columns of data frames but if i just use
the matrix notation i could do iris
then brackets comma 1 and that's going
to return the first column of
the iris data frame or i can just use my
list notation
so iris and then in double brackets 1.
now if you've seen my r tutorial 4 i
went over the fact that a data frame is
a special
instance of a list where you have
vectors that are of the same length
all a data frame is is a list so the
first element of it is the first
is the first column of it so the long
and the short of it is
all these three approaches for getting
my first
uh column return the exact same result
now similarly i've got to go over
accessing items in lists
now this is the code that i created from
our tutorial number four
now it's you should get acquainted with
just looking at the structure of a list
um now this list three that i created
it's a list that has two numerical
items here the number one and the number
four but also
a uh data frame or actually it's a table
here
but it's a tibble with uh so and so
variables all in it
now when i run the str function for that
list it's going to output all of that so
i see every component that's going into
well really i see the components of the
components on my list
now there's a number of different ways
to access the elements of a list
now if i do a single bracket here that's
going to default to returning a list
so when i did list one and then a single
brackets one
that returned a list that has just one
item in it it's just the number three
but this thing that got returned is a
list
however if i do the double brackets
that's going to return
the first element of that list without
taking that extra step of converting
that into a list
you see the difference here the single
brackets returned a list
and the double brackets returned just a
one-dimensional numerical item three
uh similarly if uh i have names here
i can use the names in the double
brackets to access
uh the element of list four that's
called scalars
and then similarly if i have double
brackets followed by a single bracket
i'm accessing the first element of the
first element
of list four if we look at list four
back up here
uh we had list one list two list three
first element of list four is list one
and then the first element of list one
is three and would you look at that
i returned three here or actually inside
of a list because once again i'm using
the single brackets now to wrap up this
discussion on data frames
a couple more functions that you
absolutely need to be familiar with
are c bind and r bind and these stand
for column bind and row bind
respectively
so i'm going to show you an example for
each of these now
for c bind uh i'm going to demo the r
norm function for it
at the end of this uh of this tutorial
but for now uh
all i'm doing is um i want to create a
vector of length 150
there are 150 rows to iris and the most
important thing here is
i want these things to be of the same
size
so then i want to create a new data
frame called c bind example
and i'm c binding the iris data frame
with this new noise vector that i
created
once again they're both of size 150 and
then when i look at the c
bind example bam i've done that with
no problem i've added this noise uh
variable to the end of uh
the iris data frame to create a new uh
data frame here called c bind example
so c bind is probably the one that i use
the more of the two and
it's pretty flexible so if you wanted to
c bind
a data frame and another data frame you
could do that i did
obviously a data frame and a vector here
and as you see it works awesome
now similarly you've got r bind now what
i'm going to do here is i'm going to
create a new
data frame called extra rows here and
it's going to be the same number of
columns as iris but it's going to be
50 rows so i'm going to do that and
just take a look at what i uh what i
create here i create an r bind example
which is going to be the row bind of
iris and extra rows
now just looking at the structure for
each of these things
iris what was 150 rows with five
variables
this extra rose thing i created was 50
rows
five columns and then bam this uh
r bind example that i created has 200
rows and five variables again
so c bind and r bind are going to make
it super easy for you to work with
with data frames we're going to go back
to our cheat sheet here and we're going
to go to the third column of the last
page here
now it has some stuff for dealing with
strings and this is all very important
but i'm going to cover this stuff inside
of a separate tutorial
i'd say the most important thing here is
the paste function because that's going
to join multiple
uh text vectors together uh and also you
have the string r package in the tidy
verse which makes it a lot easier for
dealing with your
with your character data now the next
thing that i really want to show you is
the cut
function and what this is going to do is
it's going to take a numeric vector and
it's going to cut it
by sections into a factor so let's show
you how this works
uh if we go down here i'm going to i'm
going to use this two different ways
so i'm going to create two new variables
they're going to be called sepal group
1 and sepal group 2. now there's a
couple different ways that we can
that we can use the cut function one of
them
is to break is to manually specify how
we want to cut this variable
up and the other way is you just specify
uh the number of cuts or the number of
breaks rather so you're going to break
it into the bottom 50 percent here and
the top fifty percent
because i've specified only two breaks
so if we do that here
uh i'm gonna look at the data frame
first um
for that first sample group that i
created notice that i specified
uh cut points 5 and 5.5 as well as well
the minimum
of the variable sepal length was the
first thing i specified
so we've got one group 4.3 to 5 another
group
5 to 5.5 and then similarly it
automatically figured out that 6.1 was
the median
so we've got this new variable sepal
group 2 which goes 4.3 to 6.1 and
there'd be
naturally another value for the um for
the group
for the value that's the median to the
maximum so
cut will save you a ton of time don't be
like me and
uh and ignorant to this function when
you first get to learning r and create
these by hand because
cut makes your life a lot easier now
basically the rest of the stuff on this
cheat sheet is all statistics and
distributions related
and i'm gonna show you all this again
inside of this r document here
so moving on to some really really fun
stuff and critical for any person who's
even you know got their feet wet in the
statistics world
is uh the lm function and so how this
works is you're going to specify a
formula
then the data where this for where this
formula comes from
so the data where all the variables are
coming from basically
and then the easiest way to access all
the information from uh from
the model that you create is to use the
summary function
so let's just look at a sample linear
regression model here
we've got the formula for that uh for
that uh regression at the top
we have a five number summary of the
residuals
then we've got the intercept as well as
all the slope estimates
the standard error for all those slope
estimates
uh the t statistic for them as well as a
p value for them and then
uh to make your life easier it's got
these significance codes
uh side by side these so you don't have
to you know spend too much time
looking at a big list of these and
figuring out oh well is that significant
uh you've got naturally a residual
standard error here
a multiple r squared and an adjusted r
squared and then an f statistic for the
for the broader model you've also got
the
glm function which is for generalized
linear models
probably the most common one that
everybody's going to use is logistic
regression but you've got
um you could specify family equals
poisson for something like a log linear
model
but apart from that the syntax is
incredibly similar here
i'm going to create a logistic
regression here and i have very very
similar
output here i have my regression
equation up top
i have the deviance residuals very
similar output here with the estimates
standard error for them a z statistic
and a p-value associated with those
and then my null and residual deviance
and aic
last but not least is working with
distributions now there are four
key functions for working with
distributions here and i'm going to show
you an example for all of them for a
normal distribution
so starting with r norm this helps you
generate randomly from the normal
distribution
and the syntax here is i want to
generate 20
observations from a normal distribution
that has mean
0 and standard deviation 1.
we do that and then bam uh just from
eyeballing
uh these values here looks like uh
realizations of a normal random variable
that has mean zero and
standard deviation one there's the
lesser used density function
and we're going to evaluate the density
at point zero
for again a normal district a standard
normal distribution
that comes back at 0.398 we've got a
probability function
so uh the probability of getting 1.96
or smaller from a standard normal
distribution
anybody in the statistics universe knows
this right off the top of their head
that's 0.975 0.975 is the probability
that you uh
see a value of 1.96 or smaller
and then you could do one minus that
obviously if you want the complement
uh but then we can do this in reverse
so if you want to do the quantile
function so
plug point nine seven five what is the
value for which point we get to the 97.5
percentile of a standard normal
distribution
uh bam we have 1.96
so there you have it this cheat sheet i
think provides a really comprehensive
rundown
of some of the most important
functionalities in bass
are and if you're a beginner to r i
strongly recommend
bookmarking this cheat sheet again the
link to it is going to be in the
description of this video
and naturally you do have to get used to
using other packages for the
functionalities they offer
but just get used to using the base r
functions
and obviously getting used to calling
the help documentation
so you remember the syntax so you can
just look up the syntax
and this doesn't just feel like
memorization to you
and at a certain point of time it's
going to just feel like second nature to
you and you're going to be able to do a
lot
even without even even having to dabble
with packages just using base r
so that's it for this tutorial if you
enjoyed it and you found it of value
please consider
sharing it otherwise again hit the like
button and then i'll see you all in the
not so distant future
until then richard on data